[Music]
and
today in in this presentation i would
like to share with you
how to scale shiny to thousands of users
um my name is damon rajevich and i'm of
the founders of epsilon
and i'm also a technical person so i
worked hands-on
on a lot of projects that we have that's
why i have a first-hand experience in
scaling shiny applications
be sure to leave your questions i'd be
happy to discuss them and you can
contact me later if you have
any further questions to discuss so let
me start with a very simple success
story that i keep seeing over and over
again and i'm really excited about this
thanks to shayani you and your team are
able to build a successful app
very quickly sometimes it is just a
matter of days and you start having your
first
[Music]
clients customers users very often these
are
internal users in your own company you
are helping them
understand better their process and go
through the process much faster
and suddenly you have more users that
are using your application
um very often we see that people who
start using your shiny application
love it from the first day because the
fact is that thanks to shiny
you are able to implement new features
very fast and shiny is super flexible
you just make the changes on the go
everyone loves the application and
it does exactly what people want to do
because this is
a dedicated software that you build for
them
suddenly you realize that you have a
huge amount of users that are using your
application
and there starts to it starts to become
a problem
because someone reports to you that your
application is actually
slow or some will tell you that they are
blocked and they cannot
click around your application and this
is usually when
you decide to seek for the solution and
these are usually the questions that
we are asked how to make my app faster
how to scale my shiny application
how to build a scalable shiny enterprise
application
and one thing that i would like you to
first think about
is the fact that most of those questions
usually start with
a question how we are very used to
trying to find the solution as fast as
possible
we want to find good tips and streaks we
want to understand
what's going on and just apply new
techniques
but there are two other questions that
are even more important that you should
be asking
and the first one is why and the second
one is what
let me share with you a quick story
there was a client that had
their car broken down and they went to
the mechanic
a mechanic looked at the car and they
realized that the
engine is broken they took the hammer
and just smashed the engine
then suddenly the engine started working
again and the client asked
okay that's awesome how much do i pay
for this simple service
and the mechanic says you're going to
pay hundreds of dollars
and the client wasn't happy about it and
they asked for the invoice
to see why exactly hitting an engine
with a hammer actually cost
a hundred dollars and this is the
contents these are the contents of the
invoice
the one dollar for just hitting uh an
engine with the hammer
but the 99 dollars is because the
mechanic understands
why the engine is broken understands
what the root cause is
and then knows what exactly to do
to get rid of this roots cause
and now before i jump into why which i
think is the most fundamental question
that you should be asking
let's talk about what so that you have
the whole context
of what we usually do when we want to
scale the shiny application
so when you think about scaling shiny
there are
two groups of actions that you can make
the first one is called vertical scaling
and this is increasing the amount of
users for one machine
and you can do it in two ways the first
one is just adding more resources to
your machine
so add more cpu add more memory
the second way of vertical scaling
is making your shiny application leaner
so allowing more users to use it
and the second group is horizontal
scaling which is just adding
more machines to put it in this context
first two are actually fairly simple i
know i'm very often
asked about how to scale shiny
horizontally how to have multiple
servers with connect
let me tell you this this is actually
very very simple
i'm going to share with you resources at
the end of this presentation so that you
can take a look
yourself on the contents but basically
the first
simple step that some people usually do
is just
ask the devops it if they can increase
the size of the server they add memory
they add cpu
and this right away gives you more users
that can use your application
of course um you have to pay for that
and very often
uh it is difficult to find additional
budget for increasing the machine
especially if suddenly you need say you
have 10 times as much users and
you need a really really big machine
then the second step that you can do is
talk to devops i.t and ask for them to
ask them to add more servers
this is as simple as just spinning up
additional virtual machines if you are
using cloud
or a little bit more complex if you are
if you have like physical machines that
you have to turn on
and configure but the good news is that
rcdconnect is super easy
to configure there are just simple steps
that you need to
go through and suddenly all of your
machines are going to run our studio
connect
all of them are going to run your
application
and the only thing it costs you is
actually
a real money for the machines now the
third thing that you can do
is the most difficult one and the one
that requires you to understand
why the application may be slow and this
is for you
as an our shiny engineer to find the
bottlenecks
and to understand what slows the
application down and to make the
application leaner
there are three main things that you can
do of course there is
much more techniques that you can apply
but
the key parts are first to leverage the
front end to use javascript
as you saw from the previous
presentations it's not that complex and
sometimes you don't even need to
understand the javascript if you don't
use server to generate html
and send it back to you when you make
changes it already saves you
a very valuable time of your processor
the second one is to extract
computations and this also decreases the
cpu usage of your application
if your application is doing something
heavily think about a way
to extract those computations somewhere
else to leverage
ability to use other external services
and not put all of the
pressure on your shiny application
server the third one
which is i think the most commonly used
is to just use a database i have heard a
huge amount of
success stories when someone just
decided to move all of his data
or her data into the database and
suddenly the application was
easily scalable up to hundreds or
thousands of users
this gives you two advantages which is
less memory usage and less cpu usage
so this is more or less what you need to
do
to scale your shiny application now i
would like you to fully understand
why we actually have to do this because
when you think about it
rsd connect is a great product that
allows you to scale shiny applications
up to tens of thousands of users
you might have seen sean loop's video
where he shows
how this is possible and also chinese
very fast on your local machine when you
just run it since
why should it be slower for others when
there is just
more people using it so let me tell you
a story based on a very simple
application if you take a look at the
code and this is like a more
most simple one that you can write there
is a slider
and there is a text output uh server the
only thing that the server does here
is the server gets the input slider
value whenever it changes
and sends the value back as output text
now what happens behind the scenes when
you
send such application to the server
first thing when
the user connects to the server is the
browser is going to download
html that is generated by your ui
function
css javascript all the static files like
images and at the same time server is
going to create a
separate process for you so that
you can start your shiny session there
and you can execute the r code
now the thing about processes is that r
is single threaded
and you can specify how many users you
want to have
for one process but you need to realize
that if there are two
users that have the same process
assigned
and are a single threaded then when one
process does something then
the other user cannot actually do
anything i will show you this
in a moment but what you should
understand here is that
the server creates a process or adds the
user to
already existing process to handle all
of the operations on your reactive graph
now the second thing that happens is the
browser creates a connection
through web sockets and through web
sockets
there are going to be data and
information being sent
back and forth web sockets are slightly
different than
the typical rest api that you know
because they allow you to have
a bi-directional communication and
that's why the server can actually push
some messages to the browser
which is not that possible with a
symbol typical applications that have
rest api
so the the second step is the browser
actually binds the shiny
inputs and outputs and it starts the
websocket connection with the server
now let's say that you are moving the
slider and you set the slider to
five the browser is going to send this
value to the server
the server is going to check this value
trigger the reactive computation and
return
the resulting value so in our example it
is just going to
respond to the browser that text is 5.
now
coming back to the pedro's presentation
if instead of just
returning a simple value we returned an
updated widget then you would actually
have to
send the whole html if you don't use the
update
function that pedro was talking about if
you used update function
then the browser is smart the browser
receives only the data that has changed
and in java on the javascript part is
going to update the html
so this is a huge value already by using
the update functions
now when it comes to the browser and the
server
after the all of the computations are
done the browser is just waiting for
another signals either from the user
or from the server now this is a very
simple example
and now let's take a look what happens
when you actually start doing some
difficult computations instead of just
returning the value
i'm going to perform a long complex cpu
operation
based on the input slider value and now
the same thing that happens you send
the value through the web sockets to the
server
and within that process that is started
for you the
process is just calculating uh the
long-running computation that you
required
him to do and the problem is that your
user no longer
is able to make any actions within the
application everything is gray
it is waiting for the output and at the
same time
new users or old users that have already
been using this process
also cannot interact with the server and
have to wait for this computation
to finish and this is one of the main
issues that we see in
applications when there is plenty of
complex computations happening for one
users
the other users are blocked or the cpu
usage is so high that
the other users are seeing that things
are going
slower for them so in order to
get rid of this problem you can use
multiple solutions first one
extract some computations to the
database i will show you this in a
moment
second one you can use shiny promises
which is a great package
by joe chang that create allows you to
move those computations to a completely
new process and
makes shiny free from any computation
you can use shiny worker which is our
package for similar computations
or you can simply move some of the
computations to the javascript to the
front end
now let's talk about the database this
is the second biggest problem that i see
in applications
you might create a successful
application that works locally fine
but in fact the application in order to
run
loads a lot of data into memory and we
need to realize that
our computers and are similar to what we
have
as servers they they have their own ram
they have their own cpu
and ram usually is around 16 32
gigabytes it's not a lot
if in your application you read one
gigabyte of data
and then you filter this data to do some
actions in the application
let's see what happens in the real life
you can see a machine here
you can see five users that are
connected to rsd connect
and in this configuration we create one
process
for every two users that access our
application this is configurable this is
easy to configure
but for this purpose uh let's assume
that we have two users per one
process right now if you have five users
you already have three gigabytes of data
being loaded because every process is
like a
separate uh box that contains everything
that you need to
trigger all of the to compute everything
and now when you have for example 13
users suddenly you need to have seven
processes and you use seven gigabytes
let's see if you have 26 users it
already uses
apps the 14 gigabytes of data and when
you think about it
26 users is not a lot so you should be
very aware of the fact that
the usage of your memory is going to
multiply by the amount of users that you
have
in your application and you should try
to avoid loading too much
data into memory what you can do instead
is to set up a separate database
and it doesn't have to be a separate sql
server
it could be files on your drive on the
machine's drive
that are accessed in a different way
than just loading all of that
into memory you can uh check out
search online for christian igra's talk
about
different possible ways of reading data
and
even uber is having a separate package
that
basically reads a lot of files terabytes
of data that you can search this is just
files
but when you have an external database
that database contains this one gigabyte
and you just execute a filter a query
and you get the result
and here you have two games first one is
of course the fact that you don't have
to load the data into memory
but the second one also is the fact that
sometimes such filtering is even faster
because the database is specially
indexed to allow you to make the queries
very fast
so just to recap when you have a
successful shiny application
most likely from the start because it is
a prototype it is
going to look like this there is a
server there is ui a lot of
communication
through the web sockets and the server
is doing a lot of computations
by by themselves the first thing to do
try to leverage javascript try to move
some computations to the browser the
second part use external server you can
use plumber api
to create a separate server that is
going to do the computations for you and
then just ping the main server
when the computations are done you can
use the database which is the simplest
way of already giving you a lot of edge
and then you can just scale horizontally
by adding the servers
with your itt now the other way to think
about it is
you don't want your application to be a
slow chess player
you want your application to be the
forest gump of table tennis
you wanted to just take the ball and
give it back right away when the
when the application when the front end
is asking for something
you just respond very quickly hey yeah
okay i'm going to do this
and the front end knows that something
is triggered
then you just delegate your job
somewhere else and once the job is done
you treat you're letting
front end know that something has
changed this is similar to
um the comparison that i have in my head
is that
you don't want for example your mother
to come into your room and tell you
hey now you have to do your homework and
i'm going to stand here and wait until
you're finished
and you won't say just to say hey do the
homework and
i will be back or let me know when you
are finished so this is the kind of
way you want to structure your shiny
application now
to sum it up i would like to tell you
also how to do this
and there is plenty of resources that
that you can reach
uh you will we will share the slides
with you so we can click through those
links and
see different articles and there is
separate section for leveraging
front-end there is a very nice book
about javascript for r
and there is a section for extracting
computations the shiny worker package
shiny promises package
plumber api great great resources that
you can just
jump into and start working with for
using database i recommend using the
reading domain article from our studio
it actually goes through every step
that you need to have the database in
your application and to scale vertically
and horizontally
and there is a very nice page about
scaling
and performance performance tuning in
rcd connect
that gives you an overview of all of the
configuration options
especially how many users you use for
the process
and there is a separate dock about high
availability
how to scale your application
horizontally how to add additional
servers
as i said this is like really simple
don't worry about it just try it
you can even log into aws or google
cloud set up
three virtual machines install rstudio
connect and see how easy it is to
configure
that is all from me thank you very much
hope this is useful and
i'm looking forward for the next talk by
marik and philippe